all right
this is my childhood Monopoly board
it is the.com Edition
and there is a profound analogy here
between this game and the wheel of
samsara
and how to break free
so
I would like to start things off by
diving in to this point this point right
here is like the axle hole
okay and everything revolves around
that axle hole
and so
if we could just go
as a piece
around the board
and collect two hundred dollars
and then
keep going and paying for these things
along the way like rent and
food and
other basic living expenses
then and even luxurious items that we
buy what we're doing is we're endlessly
running around in circles looking at
external objects and reality and just
bouncing around
and especially if we're only collecting
so much as to then whatever we've
generated as an input just goes out
and there's when we're enslaved with
handcuffs for the entire year each year
year after year and we're not free to
think and we're not really free to live
and so the entire process is basically
questioning this wheel mechanism why am
I running around in circles year after
year doing this process earning this
style
of money whether it's whichever nation's
currency and then why am I
paying money to the people that own
these different buildings off whether
it's houses or offices
and then I'm trying to either earn my
own houses or offices my own property so
that I can then charge other people for
rent for these product Services offices
companies
so the point is to then if you want to
go on this journey of Breaking Free of
this wheel mechanism
one needs to ask what is it in this
Center axle hole what is right here and
if I access this point
which is an inner Journey right so you
have to go in
to be able to understand this
and if you do does that kind of shake up
relativity or the Monopoly board enough
to give you more freedom to feel more
Truth and Love and reality inside of
yourself
so
one has to still themselves from the
wheel mechanism
endless spinning around in order to find
slow down enough to find what is this
what is this axle hole here
you know does it have any features or is
it just like empty space
and is it infinite in that sense
and is it pure love when it doesn't have
any of these attributes
when I'm not focused on my name and my
identity my location my time
my beliefs opinions politics religion
sexuality any of those things those
identifiers and attributes when I'm not
focused on those I'm focused on just
this axle hole at the center
what happens then
what happens to the board what happens
to
my programming do I deprogram my
Tendencies my condition Tendencies
around
the board so that I can focus more on
coming from this deprogrammed place of
the axle hole of this empty space
and in doing so are my intentions less
so then about trying to acquire
different properties and then charge
others
but then my programming may change it
may become something like I want basic
needs for everyone
I want to completely change the nature
of the playground on Earth
so people can be free to be who they
want to be so I want decentralized water
food energy housing well-being Joy
Etc Freedom creativity
so that these pieces don't have to run
around the board ceaselessly doing this
activity without ever asking themselves
bigger questions and without actually
being able to
really love each other
so this is the how to break free
analogy using the Monopoly board along
with samsara and the wheel
of existence